Suppose marketing experts have
determined the relationship
between the selling price of an
item and the quantity sold
of an item can be represented
by the linear equation q is
equal to negative
30s plus 800.
Where q is the quantity sold
in a year, and s is the
selling price.
That makes sense.
If our selling price is higher,
then this whole thing
is going to become more
negative, and we're
going to sell less.
If we lower our price, we're
going to sell more.
Fair enough.
They tell us that if the cost of
to produce the item is $20,
what is the selling price that
optimizes the yearly profit?
Let's think a little bit about
what yearly profit means.
Let's think a little bit
about yearly profit.
The profit is going to be equal
to the quantity that you
sell times what?
For each unit, what you care
about is the profit per unit,
and the profit per unit is the
selling price per unit minus
the cost of producing
that unit.
The cost of producing
the unit right there
is $20-- minus $20.
That makes sense.
If you're selling something for
$30, and it costs you $20
to make it, every unit that
you sell, you'll make
$10-- 30 minus 20.
If you sell two units, it's
going to be 2 times $10, and
you're going to make $20.
Nothing really groundbreaking
right here.
Right now we have profit as a
function of q, of quantity and
selling price, but we have
quantity as a function of
selling price right here, so we
could substitute this whole
expression right here
in for quantity.
What happens to our profit
function then?
Then we can rewrite our profit
function as being equal to--
instead of writing q, we could
say it as the same thing as
negative 30s plus 800
times s minus 20.
Let's multiply this out so we
have a nice, clean trinomial.
Our profit is going to be equal
to negative 30s times s
and that's negative
30s squared.
Negative 30s times negative 20
is positive 600s, and 800
times s is 800s.
Then, 800 times negative 20
times negative 2 would be
negative 1,600, so it's going
to be negative 16,000, if I
did it right.
This right here is our profit
function, and we can merge
these middle two terms
right here.
We have our profit is equal to
negative 30s squared plus
1,400s-- just merging
these middle two
terms-- minus 16,000.
Now, we have a negative
coefficient on the s squared
term, which tells us this will
be a downward opening
parabola, and so let's think
a little bit about it.
If this is our profit axis,
and this right here is our
selling price axis, this
parabola is going to look
something like this-- I don't
know exactly what it will look
like, but it will look
something like this.
It will be downward opening.
We're asked to find the selling
price that optimizes
the yearly profit.
It's optimal if it's as high as
possible, so we're going to
look for a maximum point.
We're going to look for that
maximum point right there,
find the selling point that
gives us that maximum point.
we've seen.
This before.
That's the selling point, or
the s coordinate of the
vertex-- we need to find the
s coordinate of the vertex.
The easiest way to think of
doing that is to put this
function into our vertex
form, so let's do that.
The easiest way to do that I
can think of-- well, we're
going to come a little bit of
completing the square and all
that, but we've seen all of this
before, so let's take it
step by step.
First thing I like to do is
factor out the negative 30, so
we have a clean coefficient
on the s squared.
We could write price is equal to
negative 30 times s squared
plus-- 1,400 hundred divided
by negative 30 is negative
140/3, and you can divide
both by 10 s.
Then, 16,000 divided by negative
30 is positive 1,600
divided by 3-- you take a 0 off
of each of those, you have
a negative divided by a
negative, they cancel out.
That's what we're left with--
actually, let me write this
positive 1,600/3 a little bit
further out, so plus 1,600/3.
All I did so far is that I
just factored out this
negative 30.
What we can do now is we can add
and subtract a term here
so that the first three
terms here become a
perfect square trinomial.
That way, we can get into
that vertex form.
So what do we add
and subtract?
Negative 140/3 can be rewritten
as 2 times negative
70 over 3, so what you want to
add and subtract is negative
70 over 3 squared, or half
of negative 140/3.
You want to add that
squared, so plus
negative 70 over 3 squared.
We can't just add it to one side
without doing anything
else, so let's also subtract it
from that same side-- so,
minus negative 70
over 3 squared.
We really haven't changed the
equation at all, but we're
just adding and subtracting the
same thing to both sides.
What that allows us to do is
to make this into a perfect
square trinomial-- this is a
perfect square trinomial.
We can rewrite our profit
function-- our profit function
is equal to negative 30 times
this thing right here, which
is a perfect square-- it is
s minus 70 over 3 squared.
Then we have all of this
business over here: minus
minus negative 70 over
3 squared plus 1,600
hundred over 3.
The next thing we can do is
redistribute this negative
30-- let me scroll down,
so we have some
space to do this with.
We could say price is equal
to negative 30 times this
expression right here, which is
5 minus 70 over 3-- sorry,
not 5 minus, that's an s, and
we have to be very careful.
That's our selling price s minus
70 over 3 squared, and
then that's negative 3 times
its first term, and then we
have to multiply negative 30
times each of these terms.
It's negative 30 times this,
and a negative times a
negative is a positive-- 30
divided by 3 is 10, so it's
going to be plus 10 times
negative 70 squared, which we
could evaluate if we want.
Negative 30 times 1,600 over 3
will be negative 10 times 3--
it'll be negative 16,000.
We can simplify this.
Negative 70 squared is what?
It's positive 4,900 times 10,
and you get 49,000 minus
16,000, which is 33,000.
We might as well do that, so
this whole thing simplifies to
our profit function-- our yearly
profit-- is negative 30
times s minus 70
over 3 squared.
Let me make sure I did that
right: 7 times 7 is 49, and
then you have-- no, it's
4,900, so let me
be very clear here.
It's 7 times 7 is 4,900, and
then times 10 is 49,000.
Let me make sure I got it-- yes,
49,000 minus 16,000 is
33,000, so plus 33,000.
It's just like that.
When is this thing maximized?
If you look right here, this
term right here-- this s minus
70 over 3 squared-- is always
going to be positive, or it's
always going to be non-negative,
it could be 0.
So when you multiply times a
negative number, it's always
going to be a negative, so this
thing is always going to
be non-positive-- it could
be equal to 0.
So, the profit is going to take
its highest value when
this whole expression is 0.
And when is this whole
expression going to be 0?
The whole expression is going
to be 0 when s is
equal to 70 over 3.
That's when it equals 0.
Just so we have a better sense
of that, what is 70/3?
That is-- 3 goes into 70, 3 goes
into 7 two times, 2 times
3 is 6, bring down it down and
get a 10, 3 goes into 10 three
times, 3 times 3 is
9, and subtract.
You get another 10, so it's
23.3333333-- you can view it
that way, it just
keeps repeating.
Or, you could say the ideal
selling price is $23.33.
So, the ideal selling price, the
maximum selling price, the
selling price that optimizes
our profit is $23.33.
When you do sell for $23.33,
this is going to be 0, that
whole thing is going to
be 0, and your profit
is going to be $33,000.
At that point, your profit
is going to be
$33,000 for the year.